for years in my classes and talks and
video work I've been telling stories of
one sort or another usually to
illustrate some sort of point and I've
never really done much storytelling just
on its own in in the case of these
videos although it's something that we
do quite a lot in my family and in my
circles of friends not in any sort of
polished professional way like you might
see going to those those storytelling
outings or events but I thought it would
be kind of cool to start telling some of
my own stories that I remember from you
know my childhood my my teens and 20s
from other points so here is the very
first one of those when I was a child
growing up in 70s out on the border of
the village of Wales and the township of
Delafield in a subdivision that never
really took off for four years called
the hills Adela field where my my dad
now having a good job had a house built
for us that took quite a long time to
furnish and actually finish out you know
we had bare wood floors for her quite
some time and carpeted one room at a
time as he drew on his paychecks to do
that growing up out there one of the
rare treats for us that we would indulge
in maybe once a month or so was getting
to go out somewhere for dinner and there
was a hot dog and root beer stand called
dogging suds that we could drive to that
was near the intersection of Highway 83
which is a state highway and interstate
94 almost nothing else out there at that
time it was just all woods that was that
was actually liked by Delafield which is
to the north of Wales and we really
lived much closer to Wales we were like
basically on the border there and I
ended up going to Wales Elementary and
we actually had a phone number for
Genesee Depot which is even further
south
of their in any case you know there was
the dog in suds and there were a few
other places that we could go to there
was a supper club and then eventually
there is this place called Max's and
Max's was a tavern so there was this is
a place that my dad and then later when
he came to live with us my grandpa would
would go and have some beers and it was
kind of your typical 1970s Wisconsin
tavern not very well lit kind of grimy
smoke everywhere cuz everybody smoked
constantly including my dad and my
grandpa and he would sometimes stop
baloff after work he worked in Milwaukee
and had about an hour commute sometimes
he'd stop off and have a beer and then
come home and sometimes we would stop
there for other things and what I
remembered most about it before it
became a place where you could actually
have have supper and they had a few
things you could eat there mostly I
think like chips or maybe they could
make hamburgers or something was you
know my dad would come in and he would
sit down and there they'd pour a beer
and he'd sit there and [ __ ] chat with
the guys and he'd give me some quarters
to go play some games and one of the
things that was really interesting I
mean arcade games were becoming big in
the the late 70s and so you could play
some of those but they had this bowling
game and my sister and I used to love to
play it and it you know I should
research this I've never found it
anywhere else you had something like a
puck except it was made out of metal and
you pushed it down the the aisle which
was you know supposed to represent a
bowling alley and it was it was kind of
waxed and it would like run over things
and then these these pins would go up
and it was essentially an analogue
machine although I think there might
have been some digital components to it
like the scorekeeping mechanism again
kind of one-of-a-kind thing I've never
seen it anywhere else and we used to
love playing game and of course it
consumed quarters and quarters were
quite a bit of money back then so you
know you had to kind of nurse them you
didn't play them all
once you know I suppose you know rich
kids probably could but if you were we
were sort of solidly middle class then
when my dad was alive and and working
and and we were doing what we felt to be
quite well so Max's was a place where
you know I would see my dad hanging out
with these other guys who I didn't know
and they'd all be you know smoking
sitting around the bar chatting about
different things and he'd be there with
his you know white hair and his his you
know salt-and-pepper moustache looking
older than his years you know having a
beer and talking with them and then
eventually Max got real smart and he
realized that there weren't a lot of
restaurants around in the Wales area
other than you know the whistling toad
down to the South which is a supper club
which kind of pricey so he decided to
build an addition and in the addition he
put out a whole bunch of tables so it
became a restaurant and he started doing
Friday fish fries and so this was a big
thing for us you know now we could
actually go out more than once a month
because there would be specials so we
could save some money and the food was
really good I I remember it being quite
tasty and so by then my grandfather my
dad's dad was living with us and it
would be all five of us that is my mom
my dad my grandpa my sister and then me
all going out and getting a table and
we'd sit around and chitchat and do all
the sort of things that you'd have in a
place first of course the bread would
come and you know they tell you don't
want up on bread you know and we'd have
the option of getting kiddie cocktails
which would be like a Shirley Temple
which i think is just like basically
grenadine and soda
maybe with something else there's a like
a cherry added to it we could get
grasshoppers but they were not alcoholic
as far as I know you know and here's the
story that I really want to tell because
I think it's kind of a funny one so you
know we would go to this fish fry and he
had all these different options and that
was really cool too because you know I
think we kind of take this for granted
now you go into a restaurant
there's like a million different
possibilities just about anywhere that
you you might go and a lot of places
back then just didn't have that sort of
variety or what they had wasn't really
that good so max is it was basically
like stakes of different sorts I think
he also had like pork chops and chicken
and then because it was Friday you had
all sorts of fish stuff so you had like
you know your choice of different fish
you could get shrimp you could get
Lobster you could get combination plates
of different sorts and I remember I was
10 years old when my dad and my grandpa
made a bet now I was a kid who could eat
and you know looking at me now you might
say yeah well of course you were I was
super super skinny I was so skinny from
like you know my childhood into my early
teen years that I didn't like to wear
short sleeve shirts because they showed
how skinny my arms were as it turns out
my adopted dad my dad you know I'd
usually just call him he also was like
super skinny as a kid I was so skinny
that my ribs like stuck out and and I
could eat and eat and eat and eat and
they'd seen me eat my dad my grandpa you
know like my dad would make ribs and
they they talked about me eyeing up
stuff like I'd be eating and I'd already
be looking at the next thing that I was
gonna get like a you know cob of corn or
ribs or whatever it was gonna be right
and so my dad said to his dad
I bet Greg can eat a full sized steak
and a lobster tail because that was one
of the options it was like one of the
big entrees that you could get for Max's
place and my grandpa said no that kids
not gonna eat that much there's no way
that's gonna happen and they said this
after I'd already like loaded up on some
Brad and I think we had hors d'oeuvres
too another thing that they bring is
like pickles and olives and carrot
sticks and stuff like that and you know
being the kind of kid I was I eat
everything that was put in front of me I
didn't even eat the parsley off the
plate the non-functional garnish so my
dad said well what do you think are you
still hungry enough can you can you eat
this I think it was like a 12 ounce
New York strip steak and a big lobster
tail and these were not little lobster
tails like the the restaurants that can
are kind of cheap give you is this thing
was like you know big size right and I
was like yeah of course I can and I
never had lobster before that too so I
was kind of taking a chance but I was
the kind of kid who almost like eating
everything anyway the only thing that I
didn't like that we would have sometimes
was liver and that's a whole different
culinary conversation so you know they
you know they shake hands and they bet
ten bucks that's a lot of money back
then right in the 1970s and then my dad
said listen if you win this you win me
this ten bucks
I'm giving you five bucks of that money
and I said oh okay now I've got a real
incentive and I that I turn to my
grandpa and I said what about you what
if I lose and he said you're not getting
anything for me I'm keeping the whole
ten bucks and so now I have like a
double incentive actually triple
incentive I love to eat and I wanted to
like you know help my dad out and I was
gonna get five bucks out of it which
could go quite a long way I mean back
then a candy bar was a quarter so you
know think about how much candy that
could could buy so they bring it out and
it's on this giant plate right so I
started you know cutting into the steak
and it's good you know and I start
eating the lobster tail and that's good
too you know and I'm filling up and
filling up and I more or less like wolf
the whole steak down and probably in
retrospect what I should have done is
eat the lobster first and then eat the
steak after because the lobsters richer
and you know I get I get all of that
then and then there's probably like a
third of the lobster tail left on the
plate and I'm feeling really like
stuffed like full you know like to the
point where I don't know if I can eat
anymore
and my grandpa's looking he's like see I
told you he's not gonna be able to eat
that and that kind of put me over the
edge I was you know I won't say I said
like screw you or anything like that I
was I was not that sort of kid back then
I would become so later on but I was
like well who are you to tell me I can't
eat all this food and so you know I'm
still
there and it was I'm not gonna say it's
like a marathon or something silly thing
like that but it was an effort to you
know eat this stuff I kind of felt like
I might you know throw up or something
but I'm forcing the food down and my dad
and my grandpa and everybody else around
the table too is watching and then
people at the other tables are all kind
of in on it as well because they've
heard my dad and grandpa talking and my
mom is getting a little bit you know
sort of alternately embarrassed and also
enjoying the attention I don't know what
my sister was doing because I was
concentrating on that plate I was you
know single-minded I like I'm not gonna
throw this up because I don't lose the
bat you know I'm gonna get this food
down and then I'm gonna get my my five
dollars in my moment of glory and I did
it you know I got it down and I won't
say that I actually enjoyed the last bit
of that meal the way I did the front end
of that meal but I managed to do it and
then you know my grandpa paid over the
ten bucks and my dad gave me the five
bucks right there and then we you know
eventually they had dessert I didn't
have any dessert
of course that's just sitting there and
you know just stuffed to the gills as we
say and then we went home and I had kind
of a stomachache but I had five dollars
more I didn't have a wallet back then
and five dollars more in my pocket and I
knew that I could do it and that I liked
steak and lobster together so you know I
kind of learned some sort of less than
in the process and so did my grandpa
don't bet against this kid eating stuff
so there's my story not a particularly
edifying one but perhaps an interesting
and enjoyable one
you